hey guys today i'm going to show you how
to pose couples
hi my name is jerry gionis i'm a wedding
portrait and fashion photographer i've
been shooting for 27 years and teaching
for 20.
i'm going to share some of that
experience with you right now by
teaching you
how to pose couples and how to go from
this
to this by the way guys i have an
amazing course the photography quick
start
it's a free download and you can
actually enjoy this by clicking the link
right up here
or down below so you have a couple in
front of you
what do you do they're standing like
this they're waiting for a photograph
now cute couple
but we have to bring out a little bit of
finesse now usually when i'm
photographing a couple i start with what
i call the safe shots
it's like you do what you have to do to
do what you want to do so get the shot
clean shot looking in the camera smiling
no problem
and then you can keep on going from
there now depending on whether this is
photographing for a wedding
photographing for an engagement session
photographing a couple whether it's a
young couple an older couple
just get it cleanly done now when
they're looking at the camera
i'm okay with the hands uh of the guy
for example being in the pocket or being
on his side
i'm okay with the hand being on the hip
for the girl or whatever it might be
doesn't really matter because we're not
really trying to convey romance or
anything like that
it's a clean classical traditional
photograph so in this case they're
standing like this so
now rainey's just sort of you know
politely sort of waiting and she's
actually
trying to put her weight off her legs a
little bit like this there's a little
bit of finesse to what she's doing but
it's important that we adjust her
accordingly
so first of all if you are photographing
a couple and you're suggesting
a relationship or intimacy in some kind
of a way it's important that they turn
their bodies
actually towards each other so let's do
that on a 45 degree angle make sure your
shoulders touch sort of right at the end
as you can see bring your arms around
each other so right there keep your
hands on the side
so this hand's in the pocket so we can
see jacob's hands in the pocket
and rainey's hand is right here on the
hip
now let's uh let's pay attention to a
couple of things
now jacob if you bring your hand up a
little bit higher on this side and bring
it more this way
now you can see this is a common mistake
we can see his left hand
right on the thinnest part of the waist
it's a little bit higher because she
already had
her hand on her hip but i don't like
that hand popping out of nowhere
now i'm happy to sacrifice perfection
for emotion as in
you know he's drawing you know the woman
he loves
close to him and that's fine but i feel
like i just want to lose that
distraction
if it's not adding something to the
photograph it's probably taking away
so in this case that hands are
distraction so we'll get rid of that
left hand
now um bring your left hand right on
there as well
now we established the the male pose
which is basically for me as far as i'm
concerned
we turn his body on a bit of an angle we
actually are going to photographing him
oh sorry we're going to photograph him
um
with his leg bent as close as the camera
as well as
the common denominator is that her leg
that's close to the camera is also bent
watch what happens when we actually put
all the weight on the front leg
of rainey's so now what's happening is
we're whiting that dress
there's a little bit more junk in the
trunk so to speak it depends on if you
want that
the good thing about the world we're
living in today we're celebrating you
know
uh curves and things like that that's
fantastic so if you wanted some more
curve there
you could put the weight there but you
can see there's a disconnect it's almost
like the lower part of your body is
facing this way
and then her upper body is facing that
way there's a disconnect so i don't like
that so we're going to shift her weight
and put all the weight in the back leg
so let's start from scratch here for a
second
stand shoulder to shoulder flat footed
looking at me
okay so right now i'm going to
photograph that portrait you may have
seen this kind of shot
and that is sort of like the uh oh what
do you call it
that that that fork um
what is that uh american gothic there it
is
so you may have seen that shot the the
the painting the american gothic
it's um it's flat to the camera they're
very stoic and it's been popularized
in our industry for the last several
years and it's perhaps been and gone but
i feel like standing there with no
emotion
that's exactly it there's no emotion it
doesn't make me feel anything
so i don't want that shot i want a
little bit of finesse
so now let's turn our bodies towards
each other keep the feet flat-footed for
a moment so come nice and close together
again
okay so the hands are by this side at
least their bodies are turned to each
other there's some kind of emotion
happening there
let's take a shot like that for the
moment okay
but there's nothing going on let's go a
little bit further one step further
bring your arms around each other the
ones furthest away from me
great stop there keep the feet
flat-footed okay so right like that
great so now what we'll do is we'll
leave jacob where he is
we'll we won't move him an inch at all
i'm going to get rainy to point your toe
towards the camera slide the heel back
in
bend that knee a little bit right over
like that good
hands on the hips and now you'll notice
this
it's really important that the web of
the hands
meet and marry up to the thinnest part
of her waist
so if you let's say you had a plus size
girl or a little bit more curvy and you
wanted to soften those curves a little
bit
you might deliberately put that hand
over where it looks a little bit thicker
in my perspective my humble opinion the
common denominator and what's going to
look good
with most girls the web of the hand
between the thumb and the forefinger
go on the thinnest part of the way so it
brings attention to that area
so we do that fantastic so rainy's
looking good
she's turning her body away from the
light source she's looking straight to
the camera for the moment no problem
and she's bending her knees so we're
getting these beautiful curves
now let's take that shot the problem
with that is
she's looking great but he's just doing
nothing he's like
well we've got curves for her he's just
looking straight up and down
there's not much finesse now watch what
happens see we've got the hand on the
hip for her let's put his hand in his
pocket
okay let's do that shot but then he
still looks a little bit stoic
there's something there's no energy
shifting to the girl that he loves so to
speak
so now what we're going to do is he's
going to just lean a bit more forward
and then lean into rainy
then and then automatically you see what
he did he actually bent that front knee
which is fantastic
so putting all his weight on his back
leg and then bending that front knee
is really good so now we put their faces
nice and close together
perfect turn the bodies in a little bit
slightly perfect
very good and we take that shot that's a
lot more for nest
than where we started so if you look at
those shots that we just did
we've got the finesse of that then
you've got basically her looking good
but him very stoic
him with the handout and then very
straight
and then of course doing nothing looking
at the camera great so now we have that
foundation you've seen that progression
from literally stoic flat looking in the
camera to at least some kind of finesse
and then now we're looking in the camera
but in a more of a finesse way
so if i wanted to see the dress see the
suit i would not getting them holding
their hands in front of the camera right
now in front of them
otherwise it would just cover up the
dress and cover up all these different
things
so a couple of things if you're going to
get them to hold hands so
just hold hands in front with these ones
in the front so do the exact same pose
so the exact same pose so hold each
other like that and hold like that great
okay so
he sort of knows how to hold her like a
gentleman okay that's a nice little
delicate way if he slides his hand back
a little bit
and then we bring that down a little bit
and just make sure
jacob your left hand we can actually see
it there
uh and you know what we'll do actually i
want to do it in a bad way so we can
show you
bring that elbow running this way and so
bring it down a bit so
so turn your body outwards again just
simply where you are like this just
bring your elbow like that bring it
right down
that's it and a bit like this bit more
good okay and then bring it flat up
against your body and then bring the
shoulder down
okay so what you're seeing right now
eyes of the camera
so what you're seeing right now although
rainy's got a great figure she's putting
her arm against her body and making the
arm look flat
and larger than it actually is we don't
want that also
i can't see the silhouette of her of her
figure and her curves right down here so
what we're going to do is this
if we bring their hands down stop there
for a second
then bring the elbow back this way stop
there too much go back
beautiful and down a little bit now we
see a little bit of a gap between her
elbow and her body therefore we can see
her silhouette
when the face is touching again okay
perfect so there's a way of actually
photographing a couple
holding hands but also getting the curve
of her
and that's basically it now let's say
for example you had a plus-sized girl
and had a little bit of weight in this
area you can adjust these hands to a
point
where we're going to hide and soften
those areas
now don't forget too posing for the
camera is one thing but changing the
angle will change the whole perspective
of what's going on so let me explain
by the way very important to know this
that whenever you're photographing
someone
if you get them to mirror you it's the
easiest way for them to actually
understand what you want from them so if
you guys hold hands there for again for
a second
and you guys nice and close together so
if i
said to you guys i want you to mirror me
and i did this
makes sense you see how easy that is
turn your faces that way perfect
so straight away they know what to do
because they can see it the problem is
before they even mirror you
you have to know what you're doing to
give them something to mirror
so let's come back again so let's say
for example we've got that pose
sometimes what i do is when i'm
photographing couples i'll say to them
guys pretend you're on a turntable and
then i don't change a single thing
pretend you're on a turntable and now
i'm just turning that turntable that way
yep keep on going mate kim and going
good stop there so bend that knee in
there ronnie
good close the gap and then looking out
that way assuming i was from that
perspective
now so if you look at that particular
shot from this angle
it doesn't look as good because now
rainey is completely flat to the camera
and now we've got jacob completely at
the side of the camera so you for
example may have a second shooter
shooting from a different angle they
might get
decent light because you've actually
posed them according to the light
but you're not getting the great angle
but remember too though there's going to
be some poses that are going to look
really really good
simply with a different angle and it's
up to you to work out whether it looks
good or not
quite simply i look at every guy and say
if i was him right now would i be happy
with this photograph do i look good do i
look handsome am i getting a double chin
am i getting a gut what's happening if i
was photographing her i'm photographing
my wife for the day
would i like those curves do i want her
to look a certain way do i want her to
look boxy and so on and so forth
but right now though we're specifically
talking about posing couples
which means that we're suggesting some
kind of intimacy and romance or some
feeling together
so we started with that beautiful
traditional shot let's do that again
so starting again by holding hands on a
bit of an angle there
okay so close again so let's say for
example
if you got the couple to look at each
other let's do that
now they're so close they're almost
going cross-eyed and it's a bit weird
right
so look at each other for a moment
okay it's weird when you're that close
especially even a little bit closer you
wouldn't really be looking at each
other's eyes
you'd either be kissing and or about to
kiss
so of course they're not a real couple
we're not going to get them to kiss but
what could be a really good shot is this
i might get them to turn a little bit
more to each other so a little bit more
side on
four heads touching good now if you now
this is really cool this is what i'm
happy about
now finally jacob looks like he has a
double chin
now he doesn't but it's the way i posed
him because he's wearing a turtleneck
and now the skin is gathering by simply
bringing his chin down because that's
what happens to normal people
under those circumstances but here's how
we're going to fix it so let's go nice
and close
and show you how we're going to fix it
so go close again
don't be conscious of it but you can
sort of see the gather of his chin here
first of all we simply can say to him
just bring your chin up like a turtle
okay so straight away we've fixed that
also if you look at
the intimacy of that photograph if i i
say guys pretend my
my hands are your faces and i say do
this so
start again from there now turn this way
stop so now you get their profile but
you see more of what's happening so now
look diagonally into each other and stay
there for me
so now we're going to go back just first
of all
let's do that double chin shot so let's
let's just look at each other that's it
perfect good
hold it
okay now chin forward like a turtle
yeah that's it now um jacob surpass her
a little bit on this side come a little
bit closer to me
so not so much your body just bring your
face so right now you're there just come
a little bit sort of more that way
that's it just there okay
now bring your foreheads touching again
sort of more evenly
and then turn your faces outwards
towards me like you did before good
chins up
good eyes down into each other beautiful
eyes
just looking right on the ground there
mate right under feet there you go just
that move beautiful
now if they're a real couple i might
even crack a joke and say hey jacob look
at the view
and then sometimes the guy's like oh my
dude not the freaking view the view dude
like
and now that makes him laugh and now
we've sort of broken the monotony of
of the posing so remember guys stop
demonizing posing posing is really
bringing out the best in people because
they don't know what they look like it's
up to us to learn how to bring out the
best in them
but again let's go back to our mandate
for this episode and that is how to
photograph couples
so we've got a nice traditional shot
looking at the um looking
into each other as a bit of an almost
kiss but here's how you can vary up the
pose really really quickly
and get a couple really cool shots um
and that's i'm glad you remind me of
this actually jacob so
you've got your hand in your pocket um
bring
your let's say rainy bring your hand on
his chest
okay perfect so now her hand is actually
very delicate i love the way
see here's a big problem when we're
posing
women's hands on men's chest sometimes
it's flat on the chest like this it
doesn't look that great
so what we want to do is just just
actually do that again
it just doesn't work it's just flat
doesn't look good at all but just
softly and then out like that doesn't
look good at all
now go nice and delicate like we did
before that slight little bend now
thankfully i've worked with ronnie
several times so she knows exactly what
i'm about to do
so she's making my life a little bit
easier but it's a little bit more
delicate and it just
it just curves beautifully and there's a
bit more emotion attached to that
now you can see how her hand is quite
emotional on him but his hands in the
pocket so if we go back to that
particular
foreheads touching shot and then we
just do that the faces are saying i love
you the hand is saying
i love you his hand is saying i don't
really care
so what i want to do is i want to get
take his hand away
okay just relax the jacket a little bit
and hold her on the waist
just in the waist there now it's
important we said before we don't want
his left hand on the other side covering
up the thinnest part of his waist
but we also don't want this hand to
cover up the thinnest part of his waist
so
for her waist so we're going to slide
that hand back into your mate stop
too much come back stop there we go your
left hand i can see your fingers pop out
okay now forehead's touching
and now you can see that that's a nice
little delicate pose now here's one
thing that's happened wrong with this
she squished her arm up against her body
and i want to separate her arm from her
body so bring it back again
so here's what we're going to do bring
their upper bodies
guys keep your feet there but your upper
bodies lean towards the camera
stop close the gap now bring the elbow
off
stop beautiful now that's a great tip if
you're
shorter or as i like to call you down to
earth you're closer to the earth
you get the couple to lean towards you
so you become parallel to them
but in this case i simply did it so that
if she just
put her arm off her body because i
didn't want that i'm pressing up against
the body
she's going to look like a chicken wing
like what's what's up with that
but if i do this to the camera and then
i just tilt down
now my arm is parallel rather than the
elbow being close to the camera
there's all these little nuances that
you just have to to work out but
certainly we're giving you these ideas
right now so make sure you practice them
okay all right we see rainy sort of uh
fanning herself of course right now just
letting you know it's uh we are in las
vegas and i don't know what that is in
uh it's probably about 100 degrees here
in vegas which is about 37 or 38 degrees
we've got port jacob actually uh wearing
a turtleneck but it was actually his
choice and uh rainy is just fanning
herself so it's all good
all right so let's have a look at the
last shot we did okay perfect nice
little intimate shot
just to let you guys know as well by the
way so we are photographing in a garage
and we've got wind uh what i call window
light but basically it's just light
coming through a garage door
and it's just open light coming through
and that's basically it so yes posing
you have to do according to the light
and just to let you know i
am favoring the light on him where
traditionally i would probably favor the
light on her
but today's class is really about posing
so i'm focusing on the posing
and not terribly worrying too much about
the light but we will do that in a
moment to make sure it favors her as
well
what else can we do with a couple what
else can they do with their hands
what else can suggest intimacy and so on
let's go back and do that
let's close the gap again let's start
from where we were so
your hands were on the hips okay your
hands were there your foreheads were
touching you're looking into each other
great and now watch what happens do you
see all of a sudden
his leg is completely straight his legs
saying i don't really care
but his face in his hand is saying i
love you so we're going to bend his knee
great just a little bit yep perfect
awesome
so now what we do is we can simply do a
couple of variations
so um rainy if you don't mind can i get
him to sort of just
emulate a kiss on on your forehead okay
so just a little kiss on the forehead
there jacob
and then close your eyes as you're doing
it beautiful perfect
now and then rainy um turn your face
this way
so just tilt tilt til chin up a little
bit turn your face there
tilt more this way good you see how easy
mirroring is because you can see what
i'm doing
and then i want you to basically give
her a little kiss right on the cheek
there just on the cheek
yep perfect now it's important that
we don't do this if you don't mind if
it's okay
kiss her on the cheek but where your
nose is almost going into her eye
but like this is what will happen
naturally because naturally this
things organically happen and i've made
these mistakes before so
again so turn you there you go we do not
want that
so it's either sheets because she's
naturally a bit shorter
usually we're going to tilt her face
more one more one more tilt
chin right up and then kiss her right
sort of
and a little bit more towards me mate
look at me that's it and chin down
and then rainy chin right up so you get
your eye out of his nose there or vice
versa
and then give her a little bit of a dip
that'll force her face even more there
we go
perfect perfect there we go awesome
beautiful so now we get
his nose out of the eye at least not
right in the eye soccer because that's
really weird
okay now how can we use the hands to
suggest more intimacy well this is a
really cool way of doing it
so first of all let's say that she's
guiding a kiss
so your hands are on on her hips there
your
your hand your four fingers in fact
let's do it the bad way
put your hand just on his face just like
that yeah this is basically like
mom like you know your mother like
saying eat some no prosciutto good
boy
it's the way i would i'll hold my my
golden doodle and i'm a good boy
um it doesn't work or you might put your
hand like this
okay that doesn't work either because
it's just it's not working right
so what we want to do is god made our
hands like this because the ear can go
right here so the four fingers are going
to be behind the ear
so you're going to be doing this ready
yep and now turn the faces into each
other
okay perfect turn your faces outwards
towards me a little bit there we go so
see how we got rid of that chin there
again
and now do you see how his left hand is
creeped in to cover up the thinnest part
of her waist
great so we fix that never forget that
perfect so that hand is there
now if he puts his hand on her hand that
would be a little bit feminine but if he
if if he starts with her his hand on her
face
like we'll do now so let's now say
you're guarding a kiss
so i want your hand in the same position
like this perfect
so it's up to you whether you want the
rawness of the hand going through the
hair
in this case i'll just leave it like
that so you can see what the hand is
doing
now her hand watch what happens so let's
say for example let's take that shot
look at each other for a second great
now her left hand can go on his wrist
now do you see how she's sliding it down
and then slightly bending it
now turn your faces outwards towards me
good now both of you lean your upper
bodies towards me
beautiful and that's slightly turned
this way guys look at me there you go
just there perfect
and now looking into each other like
that
beautiful relax do you see the
progression of that particular sequence
how everything made a difference with
what we're doing
okay that gives you a few examples to
start off with in terms of something
traditional
and then hugging and then maybe kissing
and all that kind of stuff
now let's say for example we wanted to
do it a little bit of a different way
and we wanted to take advantage of the
direction of light
so and we wanted to favor her let's do
that so let's switch sides
okay so now it's all in the way you ask
it took me years to work out the
following phrase
now let me first of all
let me first of all ask this in in a way
where it might confuse the couple
so guys if i basically said i want you
to hug
and rainy i want you to hug
his left leg with your right leg what
would that look like
okay so she did it actually too good so
[Laughter]
okay but if i said that you i mean
you're probably being a lady about it
but you'd probably do something like
this right
and that it would just look a little bit
cheesy and a little bit hammed up and
it's like uh
it doesn't look that great so what we
want to do is we want to adjust that leg
and ask it in a way that gets the result
that i want so if i say this
jacob you can come this way mate i say
rainy can i ask you
to embrace jacob's leg with your leg
but make sure your toe touches the
ground perfect
so you see how now straight away we've
got the curve
on her body we've got that round curve
on her butt line as well
but his leg is very straight so let me
just take a quick shot of that first
now i want you to slightly come back a
little bit there mate with one step
and that's it good and then slightly
bend your knee good
perfect now both of you if you can
pretend like you're on a turntable and
you're turning towards me
there you go do you see how that angle
works a lot better because before
her left leg looked a bit too straight
but now her right leg is covering that
perfect so now what we're going to do is
we're going to actually suggest that
maybe he's whispering in her ear so
let's do that so whisper in her ear
on the other side so i can't see good
chin up for me
okay so good say that there's a few
problems with that and i'll fix it in a
moment
good so the problems with that is that
he's looking off into nowhere we think
because we're saying
kiss the cheek and on the other side of
the face we can't see it
but even if we can't see his eyes if we
don't get him to put his face down and
turn his face left
he will not look engaged so bury your
head into her head there
and then where i can't see you so
literally there we go just there perfect
good chin up for me rainy so if the
light's coming from this direction which
it is look at that beautiful shadow on
her face
that's looking amazing let's take that
shot
close your eyes there ready for a second
good now her right hand is disappearing
into nowhere
so we've done the shot with a hand on
the chest let's see what a hand looks
like on a bicep
so randy do it like this okay so
a bit more relaxed but this is a common
problem let's go again so bury your head
into her face again there
on that side beautiful hold it there
that doesn't look good it looks like
this she's tackling him for something
now let's just even slide it back this
way
so no no same position there jacob so
you stay where you are rainey's doing
all the work here
so bury your head into into her neck
that's it beautiful so now what we're
doing is
we're going from this and i roll the
hands around
now that is more finesse there's a bit
more
more beauty in that now look at look at
her figure gorgeous curves
love the hand over there the arm is
slightly off the body
chin up closing the eyes jacob just get
rid of your hands on the other side
beautiful hold it there hold it
beautiful
now what does a hand look like on a
wrist let's slide it down
perfect let's relax that a little bit go
a bit more further
so i always like to start off up here
even like actually poorly
that's it don't move hold it there and
then
slide it around and gradually slide it
into you stop there perfect
good hold it there chin up close your
eyes
now in this context i actually don't
care if his hand is com
some somewhat hidden because that's the
nature of the pose
if i usually like to have gaps between
body parts
but when you've got a couple
intertwining i find that's more than
acceptable he can bring his hand a
little bit lower
but that might feel like he's about to
grab the butt that's a bit cheesy we
don't want that
and also if you wanted let's say a gap
between
her elbow and her back which gives her
more of a silhouette
then she would simply slide the hand
down so keep on going down this way
and then put your hand on his hand see
what's happening here guys is that her
hand on his hand he's saying
i like where your hand is so it's all
about body language
okay and if you don't understand bottle
language just say well what would a
couple in love look like feel like what
would they do how would they kiss how
would they hold and so on relax those
fingers
okay so now just relax don't move
and then now just give it a bit more
finesse too much just somewhere in
between
beautiful love that gorgeous hold it
there gorgeous
but you see the difference between where
we started
and then where we got to is just so
crazy
so really really important to understand
thank you so much for watching hope you
liked the video and if so please give me
a thumbs up don't forget to subscribe
and hit the bell to get notifications
for future videos please leave a comment
so we can connect and i can answer any
of your questions
see you in the next episode and don't
forget you don't have to be the best you
simply have to be better than last week
we'll see you soon
you